[Music]
all right let's go out to Dallas Texas
and talk to Katie what's up
Katie hey John how are you hey
Katie what's up man how are you well I
was going to tell you I was at smart uh
money in Dallas back in January and I
just wanted to tell you that your God
Bless Texas performance with George was
the most iconic and legendary thing I've
ever seen in my freaking life and my
husband who's not a native Texan did not
recognize me next to him at that point
at all um it was amazing and so thank
you do you have do you have and you'll
know what I mean do you have some Texas
Def Leopard girl in there somewhere oh
my gosh are you kidding me doesn't every
native Texas Kelly's smiling and nodd in
her head she's like oh yeah oh I think
only Texans can really understand that
the State pride and just culture we have
here is probably stupid but but I'll say
when that opening Rift to Pour some
sugar on me I I saw some Aquanet fly out
of people's purses and they started
making their hair real tall real fast
and all I was like
oh we're just a few verses of we're a
few verses of this song this room's
about to get all
unhinged well it was amazing so thank
you for that well you are a saint thank
you for letting me live my high school
Rockstar dreams for just a few minutes
all right so what's absolutely well um
so the last call uh really touched my
heart um mostly because I feel the
question I have today is kind of related
to that but it's not for me it's for my
spouse um the question that I'd wrote
down was how can I help my husband see
his lack of gratitude and contentment
and how it's negatively impacting his
life in our
marriage and I feel like um when I sent
this in we had just gotten out of a a a
pretty heated discussion and I was
really upset at him for a bad attitude
that he had had around my family um for
no reason he said he was hungry but then
after we ate nothing improved and he
just basically had a bad attitude for
two hours and this is kind of been a
recurring thing and I just had enough
and I told him that I felt like he's not
grateful for a lot of things and how
it's never really um nothing's ever
really good enough and some of the
excuses that he's given previously um I
don't feel like they're valid I feel
like that's kind of the Band-Aid he's
put on them because some of the things
that he's given reasons for when things
have
changed his attitude doesn't change
towards it and some
excuses um so like one of the things was
is he's from out of state and um he says
that um you know once he got friends
down here things would get better well
he has friends now and it hasn't gotten
better um that's just one example uh we
switched churches recently he had had
some issues where we were at and he
talked like whenever we switch churches
that would improve well we have and like
it still hasn't improved and I told him
I said you know back home your best
friend who lived with you for several
years and your sister like your family
they all said that that you are prone to
depression
and so I I don't think this has to do
with where you live I don't think this
has to do I don't think it has to do
with any of that I think it's a deep
down problem that you need to go to
counseling and try to get through with
because I do know there's some childhood
trauma
um his parents were present but I I know
that he was told he was an idiot a lot
and I to do everything I can tell him
that that's not true can I love you
enough and be really direct is that cool
yes
okay I was literally thinking that exact
sentence in my
head yeah and and and what I'm going to
say is going to be hard okay and he's
not on the phone and that'd be hard with
him if he was on the phone but he's not
I just got you is that
cool okay
got a kid who told he was an idiot
growing up you're an idiot you're an
idiot you're an idiot and that's
probably the tip of the iceberg
[Music]
right and if he's like my family my wife
me and my wife she knew some but I
didn't tell her
everything yeah we were married for 20
plus years before I told
her yeah okay and so far on this call
you've said said he just gets mad for
nothing his excuses aren't valid he's an
idiot he's an idiot he's an
idiot and
so without even meaning to the same
Dynamic has been
recreated because he tells you I don't
want to go be with your family and you
say why which by the way is a is a
question in counseling that is a no
no and then gives you some answer and
you say well that doesn't count and his
little 10-year-old body says you're an
idiot then he tries to go and he hates
it and his body tries to shut him down
and then you say why do you have a bad
attitude he says well I'm hungry you're
an
idiot and I agree he's got to do his
work no question about
it but the whole cycle is starting over
do you see how that's happening in an
effort for you to say I love you so
much I want you to see how much Beauty
and joy and good stuff is around us
right
now you're trying to force him to see
something that he may not be able to see
right now and what he's hearing is I'm
an idiot I'm an idiot I'm an idiot yet
again I'm not
enough and I don't even know if he's
hearing that cognitively but I can I can
guarantee you his nervous system is yeah
well and I've tried to be in like part
of what I told him like I felt like I
wasn't enough and well and that's that's
exactly right that's exactly right um
and I know that I can't um I'm sorry no
it's okay you're good you're
good I know that I can't fulfill him
that's not a spouse's job um but I do
know that I've always
been like trying to tell him I
appreciate him and like for mowing the
yard he I'll tell him hey thanks for
doing that the yard looks great and he
just rolls his eyes and says you don't
have to thank me for that that's my job
like he doesn't appreciate that I
appreciate him and I make sure that I
that as much as I can he does he does he
doesn't have the skill set to accept a
compliment yeah and I know that got that
VI because that's
me and there are times that's why I
called you no there are times in a
meeting K sounds similar Kelly Daniel
will say no John you did good
and I'm so uncomfortable with
that and that's what I got to work on
right here's this so I guess my next
thing was like how do I support him
because he he said he would be willing
to go okay to counseling and he told me
you know I'm not want to give up on our
marriage and I'll do whatever yes I just
need to know how to support him so where
I don't make him feel even
subconsciously like he's an idiot I do I
want you to do whatever you have to do
for you to go feel alive short to
violate your marriage
vows because right now he sees his wife
is frustrated and devastated and his
body is blaming him yet
again and so the greatest gift you can
give him is to begin to stand
tall and you go work out if that's what
you want to
do M you go hang out with your
girlfriends if that's what you want to
do hey I want to go see my mom and dad I
just can't all right great man we're
going to have a
blast mhm and let me tell you my wife
did that three or four
times and then I came around to my kids
and my wife and my in-laws are making
memories and I'm not a part of I'm not
in any of these
photos I have to
change I've got to change because I want
to be a part of their
life and it was seeing
light
I saw their Radiance I saw their light I
saw these photos I saw my kids burst
into the door talking about how great my
mother-in-law is and great my
father-in-law is and they are
amazing and I had missed it because I
was exhausted I was tired and so what
did I have to do I had to change the way
I was doing my life but I could only do
that not when somebody was shining a
spotlight in my ey saying look look how
bright it is it's when I saw it in the
distance and I saw my kids waving
candles around that I thought oh I want
part of
that and it's when my wife started
saying I can't make you
better but I've got to be whole and she
went to
counseling and she started her programs
and she got a awesome group of friends
and she started writing a new book and
the whole house lit up and I wanted to
be a part of
that yeah does that make sense it does
and I have been going to counseling good
um and I think it just I don't know our
our personalities are so different and I
don't care about that that makes that
makes everything more fun makes
everything more fun in good ways I agree
and it just like I've noticed anytime
we're doing something that's like fun or
out of the normal like we got to go on
an impromptu trip recently and he he he
was so happy and so alive and it's like
when we come back to reality right and
there's not a distraction anymore
he goes back into his little cave and I
don't think it's a matter of there's not
a distraction
anymore I think he goes back to a place
where his body says well we're back to
back to your failure chamber welcome
home and you have to distract from
that yeah because it'll kill you if you
don't that's when I I've talked about on
the show that's when that's when years
ago I stopped asking people hey why are
why are you drinking so much to my God
man what
happened that that's the best way your
body's figured out how to get through a
day yeah right and so it's less about
well there he's we're back now he there
goes fun husband and now he's back to oh
just hiding out no dude what is in this
home what's in this home that his body
goes dude I got to get out of here but I
can't because I want to be a good
husband and a good dad so I just
disappear at my own kitchen
table I think that begins with
not um hey what do you want to do today
hey we're going to do this we're going
to do this don't forget this weekend I
think it starts as simply as every day
hey how can I love you today and honey
you at least owe me one
thing yeah that and he just like rolls
his eyes and okay then you grab his face
in both of your hands and you so you
don't get to roll your eyes on that
question and let him know you're serious
and I bet you if you go quit rolling
your eyes and you go do something else
and you will head off into the bathroom
his body has won it's avoided that that
interaction because that interaction is
very uncomfortable for
him but when you lean in close I bet
when you're serious and you get in close
I bet he locks in like a laser beam
doesn't he no I bet he does like I I
don't maybe I've not tried hard enough
and like may put my foot down and said
hey you can't cop out of this
right um but like I know I got the cards
um for humans for couples and he like
just checks out does not want to do it
and like he doesn't want to dig and I'm
I want to dig and and get to a root
cause of something and there's a
possibility he's a coward I don't think
that's
it there's also a possibility that if he
opens that door hell's coming coming out
yeah I think so too because there was
some stuff he shared with me in the past
that it was hard for him to say but he
did say it and it broke my heart for Him
yeah um just some personal stuff that he
never told anybody yeah and the only
healing path through that he's just
afraid he should be should be because he
he experienced it once he's already been
down that road he should be
terrified
yeah
and when you're walking through hell you
can have a bunch of people yelling at
you from behind go can't you
see or you can have somebody slide in
and put their hand in his side of inside
of his arm and grab his hand with the
other
hand and say I'm going to walk with
you but you at least got to show up and
you at least owe me how can I love you
today you owe me that okay I can start
there and here's how I would start the
whole thing honey I love you so
much and I keep pointing out to you all
the things that I want you to
see I'm
sorry I know you're caring a
lot I'm going to go to counseling I'm
going to keep going I'm going to keep
doing my work I'm going to start this
exercise program I'm going to start a
morning breakfast with the kids I'm
going to start doing these
things it would mean the entire world to
me if you would join
me but I know everybody you're whole
life has been trying to drag you along
and tell you the way you should be doing
things and tell you the way you should
be thinking about things and I'm not
going to do that anymore I love you too
much but you do owe me once a day how
can I love you and it would mean the
world to me if you ask me that same
thing and basically what you're doing is
you're setting
down the bit that inside his mouth that
has been carrying him around and he's
not going to know what to do okay
whatever and then it's going to be week
one and then it's going to be week two
and then about week three I'm almost
willing to bet email me if I'm wrong
he's going to get enraged he's going to
get pissed
off because his body hasn't hasn't been
with
somebody who isn't dragging him
around and he's gonna have an anger
season before he works through what
actually
happen that sound right
yeah I'm not like why do you think that
somebody like that would even partner
with someone in the first place um we
Mir our unfinished
business that makes
sense and my guess is that's the
question I've asked myself is like why
am the world are we why What attracted
you to me he loves you he is why he
loves
you he loves you more than life
itself and I know that because it's
exhausting for him to move about the
world and yet he tries to come towards
you as much as he can and then his
body's like we're
out yeah and you have probably spent
your
life trying to get somebody to see
something beautiful and
bright yeah my mom's always called me
her sunshine girl there you go that's
has always been that way you probably
were Sunshine both because that was your
how you just came out into the world and
probably because that is the way your
body needed to operate in the system it
was born
into
yeah and so you're going to solve
somebody you're gonna make sure they see
how light everything is and he is GNA
finally figure out why am I such an
idiot and y'all found each other and you
don't call him an idiot you love him too
much but you say that excuse is not
valid look how bright it is and he's and
you're shining a Spotlight directly in
his eyes and he's like I can't see
anything and it just becomes a dance and
so you hear me say all the time on the
show just turn the lights on turn the
music off that's what we're doing here
that's you saying hey I'm putting the
spotlight
down I can't show you beauty you have to
want to see it but I see it everywhere
and I'm going to go grab it I'm going
for
it and my God I hope you'll join me and
every day of my life I'm going to ask
you what what can I do today to love you
and I want you to ask me too you at
least owe me
that unfortunately these challenges are
solved with
connection lean
in